life where I live so isn't very
challenging we're 15 seconds to 1 so
were the world in the bathroom working
we take a shower I found myself
questioning one's had to run to the
shelter it's a life with the alarm is
constantly in your head even when it's
not on one time a rocket exploded 30
meters from where we're family and I
were hiding the rocket is filled with
nails and little iron balls designed to
maximize casualties and damage I try not
to get scared and I told myself that
people knew Gaza don't have sirens and
don't have bomb shelters and they have
nowhere to run but I still get scared my
CD family friends and forced myself have
been bombarded by missiles fired by the
Hamas organization due to this reality
we're unable to work properly sleep
properly day and night stop the shooting
we will stop shooting back the
explosions are really loud our safe
place which is our home just became
unsafe and unscary and I just think it's
really sad and scary to Livia living in
this situation of constant for you from
the unknown can make you a bit paranoid
I wish that the situation will come to
an end as quickly as possible with
genuine casualties on both sides